now one of the biggest names in
artificial intelligence has quit his job
at Google Jeffrey Hinton often referred
to as the Godfather of A.I left warning
people about the dangers of the
technology let's get more on it should
with the eyes science correspondent
Stuart Ramsey as Stuart Ramsey Stuart
Richie forgive me Stuart Ramsey's one of
ours we've got a piece coming up from
him in the next hour Stuart why is
everybody talking about AI at the moment
um in the last few months there's been a
dramatic
advance in the power of
um AI in various different ways most
prominently the chat Bots uh chat GPT
has gone through various different
iterations and just in the last few
months and also in a whole range of
other capabilities uh video
making
making videos from text making pictures
that look very realistic like that one
of the Pope you might remember wearing
the puffy jacket yeah yeah so that I
mean that's just a a tiny hint of what's
to come uh in terms of the the real ISM
of the stuff that AI could produce what
should I be most scared about we should
be most scared about
um Jeffrey Henson brought this up in his
interviews the existential risk of AI
and that's something which sounds like
it's almost out of a science fiction
film like Terminator or something but it
is possible and Jeffrey Henson is seeing
this that AI could actually end up
wiping out Humanity if we allow it to
become too powerful and that you know
how does that happen uh well over time
we develop AI we develop it into a much
more intelligent uh
um
phenomenon whatever you want to call it
than us and we start giving it power in
various different ways we start giving
access to uh energy we start giving
access to financial transactions we
start giving access to weapons and this
might happen from uh you know actors
that are not necessarily you know
responsible this might happen right you
know countries using it for uh war and
and so on
and if it becomes more intelligent than
we do and if it becomes uh able to
improve itself and able to kind of
trick humans and be more intelligent
than them we could end up in a situation
like we're in with I don't know
chimpanzees where they can't possibly
comprehend our intentions uh and we
allow them to exist because uh because
we because we want to but we need to
necessarily
okay and there was me just being worried
about whether a bot would be able to do
my job or not
um what what can we do to protect
ourselves uh there are various different
things we should be doing I mean the
first thing is what Jeffrey Hinton is
doing admittedly in a rather technical
way he was on the BBC talking about uh
you know weights and models and stuff
yesterday which I didn't think was the
best communication strategy but simply
raising awareness I think is is so
important that this potentially not now
but long term could be a serious a
serious threat in the same sense that
nuclear weapons are a threat and climate
change is a threat so that's one thing
um also I think um collaboration between
countries uh countries working together
on this as they have for things like
nuclear weapons where they've made
treaties you know to slow down the
development and one other thing which
has been brought up recently in that
letter that Elon Musk and others signed
is that we might want to ask AI
developers to pause for a while and just
try and work out exactly where this is
going and make sure that the AI is
aligned with the goals of humanity
what time scale are we talking about
well you you know just just recently
even just in the last few years people
would have said well we won't get an
intelligence that's more intelligent
than humans for another 20 30 years but
now we're talking in the next few years
people are are uh are predicting and you
know already things like gpt4 are vastly
more intelligent reasoning producing
arguments producing persuasive essays
having conversations uh much more
advanced than we uh could have predicted
even just last year spokesman for AI
might well say yeah but apart from that
we've done some really good things don't
get me wrong these are incredible tools
these are going to revolutionize all
sorts of areas they're going to make
things more efficient they're going to
make things better in all sorts of ways
um already you can you can use AI for
for all sorts of really really useful
tasks jobs like mine you know research
Administration stuff uh writing stuff
incredibly incredibly helpful and they
will just become more and more advanced
over time but uh there is if we take our
eyes off the ball and become complacent
then what Jeffrey Hinton is saying and
he's a serious guy and a kind of sober
guy not some kind of crank who's worried
about this stuff
um it could easily be that uh that we
get into a situation where it gets out
of our control and we stop being able to
comprehend its intentions